Est arrivé
fais-le
qu'un
Dire quelque chose
fais-le
Je prends de l'eau au robinet des dirigeants.
Tout ne viendra à ma place que lorsque la machine sera détruite.
C'est parti, il ne reste plus rien, que dois-je faire maintenant ?
Je vais vous donner une table, puis vous viendrez à cette eau.
Entrez
[musique]
fais-le
Que nous y resterons 45 jours pour sauver nos vies.
Ont été immergés dans l'eau mais pendant quatre ou cinq jours
Après être sortis de là nous-mêmes avec l'aide de nos
Nous avons quatre jours pour voyager, allons-y à pied
Sont
Que
La plupart des maladies ici sont liées à la peau.
obtenir de plus en plus
Les gens s'aiment beaucoup mais plus
Tout ce qui est de la peau est dû à l'eau.
L'eau sale reste ici à cause d'eux
il a des problèmes de peau
fais-le